Welcome to "Ear Biscuits", I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week, we're still at our
individual tables of adequate.
I don't know if I've got
adequate lighting this week.
We didn't think they were gonna be here.
Hey, we're both wearing gray t-shirts
Is that better
Yeah, that's great.
than being the same dimly lit round table?
That's our...
Funny thing is
is we're actually now in
contact with one another,
we shot GMM together.
So we're no longer social
distancing from each other
because we basically have formed a pod
between our families and now with Stevie.
But, here's the thing.
We thought that we were
gonna be recording this
in the studio this week
and we are gonna be
shooting some GMM in the studio this week,
but there's a bunch of
construction going on
and people in and out of the studio.
So in order to minimize
risk, we're in here again.
So we lied, we're sorry.
Oh no, we were mistaken.
We were just wrong.
We were mistaken, we were wrong,
But you know what?
We're more based up like this.
Hopefully just this one.
It is my birthday as we're recording this
as with everything else, nothing counts.
I mean, you tweeted,
I appreciate you acknowledging
my birthday on Twitter.
I will acknowledge that you
acknowledged my birthday
right now.
There was a mild
acknowledgement given
the state of the world.
I know, it's like,
we've been through so many milestones
here at my home like multiple birthdays,
multiple mother's day,
anniversaries, all types of stuff.
And it's just so, it's so hard,
to work up the gumption to,
try to make it special because it's like,
you just feel like I'm just gonna wait.
It'll be special again later.
And so, I don't know, man.
It's, and then you
compound, we're not just,
we're not just living in
a world that's a pandemic.
We're in crisis, here in America.
Yeah, well,
so we'll talk about that
a little bit because
what we're gonna talk
about when we get into the
main part of the episode is,
we're gonna be talking about getting older
and not just as two middle aged men
who are literally older now,
but just the process of growing
up and we're gonna touch
on some different stages in life.
And we're using your
questions to explore that.
Looking forward to that.
Yeah, so whether you're
in your teens, your 20s,
30s, 40s, wherever you are,
we've, been through a lot of it
and we anticipate even more.
So we'll be touching on
all that stuff hopefully.
But before we get into that,
yes, we do want to acknowledge
what's going on in the world.
I mean, last week, on "Ear Biscuits",
we were talking about that I wanted to,
because of just for my own personal health
to take a news break.
Now wisely, you pointed out at the time
that was really a decision that was rooted
in my own privilege of being
able to just check out.
And since then, and we
also, we talked about the,
the murder of George Floyd
briefly and how that we had just
learned about that, when we
recorded the night before,
and I had a lot of anger about that.
And just over the course
of the few days after that,
of course, protests broke
out throughout the nation.
They're continuing to go on right now.
We've got curfews in place in
Los Angeles and things have
really gotten volatile out there.
So we're not gonna do, I think
the thing that a lot of
times white folks like to do,
which is to be like,
"Hey, let's get together
with other white folks
"and talk about race."
I think that would be in one sentence,
that could be a little tone death.
And I think that we
have made an effort to,
as a company, but also as individuals to,
say some things during this time,
but it's difficult...
One of the things that I've
learned just pretty recently
to be conscious about is just the idea
of not just doing the typical thing
where you kinda come in and say your piece
as if what you have to
say is super important.
I had a lot of things on
my mind and on my heart
about what was happening
and it hit me that
the most strategic thing that I could do
is just talk about a little bit
about what I've been learning,
especially from black voices who actually,
understand the history of
what's going on in our country
and understand why what's
happening right now is happening.
And so instead of trying to
speak my mind necessarily,
what I did is I wrote a
letter to my former self
and tried to embody the way
that I used to think about
these issues which I was very
sure was a just and right
and logical way of thinking about them,
and I've since come to
the realization that
a lot of those thoughts
were based in my privilege,
in my whiteness, which is contrary to
what a lot of people on
the internet will say,
is not a myth.
And I'll just jump in and say,
if you haven't read the Medium
article that Rhett wrote,
I'm super proud of the fact
that he put that down on paper
or you can watch him read it,
or listen to him read it
on his Instagram page.
So here I am finally
promoting your Instagram.
Well and also my Twitter,
so you can shout me out
on Twitter and Instagram
Or Twitter.
I decided to read it because,
we talked about this
last week as well I mean,
every once in a while
something gets me and I'm like,
I have to say something and
I'll write a Medium piece,
but it kinda just hit me,
a lot of people don't read, period.
And a lot of people don't read,
Medium articles.
Take the time
to just read an article.
And a lot of people don't
wanna read something
from a guy who's famous on YouTube,
which I get that, neither do I.
But I thought that by
taking the time to read it,
I could maybe communicate
how personal it was
and also get it out there.
Because again, it's like,
I'm not trying to speak
into the culture at large,
and I'm not trying to be a voice
that is telling black people
how they should be acting
and reacting to what's going on.
That's what a lot of white
people that I know like to do.
But what I wanted to do, as I said,
the only thing that I'm an
authority on in this situation
is the way that I used
to think about this,
because I was there, it was me.
And so, I just wanna talk about that.
And so I'm not gonna rehash
it here, but like Links said,
that's what I have to
say about the situation.
Of course, as a company, we're
doing what we can to support
the movement to fight racial
inequality and injustice,
both by speaking into
it, but also in giving.
But I think, and instead of waiting until
the end of the episode to give a rec,
I wanna get my rec up
front because I think that,
rather than listen to us talk about it,
I'd like you to listen to a very,
very compelling black
voice on these issues.
And one of the books that was
the most eyeopening for me,
was "Stamped From the
Beginning" by Ibram X. Kendi.
So this is a, first of all,
thankfully he has two
versions of this book
because if you just read,
"Stamped From the Beginning",
it's a long comprehensive book.
It's a history book that covers
the history of racism
against black people,
starting even before America.
But then the majority
of the book talks about
just the history of racism in America.
Now if you're like us, if you're our age,
if you're from where we're from.
I think we grew up kinda
just thinking that,
Yeah, of course there was
racism against black people.
Back in the day, I mean, of
course there was slavery,
and then there was stuff before
the civil rights movement.
But now, it's kinda like, I mean,
Hey, we had a black president.
Everything's cool now, right?
And I think that's not
really understanding
the depth of racism in
America and what that means,
and what that has meant for
black people historically
and what that means for black people now.
So I heavily, highly as
enthusiastically as possible
recommend reading or listening to
"Stamped From The Beginning".
And if that 19 and a
half hour audible book,
is a little bit too much
for you to bite off,
he actually collaborated with,
I think Jason Reynolds is his name.
And did, I think it's
just called "Stamped".
And it's basically the teenage version of,
the content that's in
"Stamped From the Beginning".
It kinda changes the voice
and speaks a little bit in a less academic
and more like to speaking
to this generation.
And it's a shorter read,
but it's essentially the same content.
So, "Stamped" by Ibram X. Kendi.
Okay, I can get into that.
Yeah, and I would just
say again the tendency,
and this has been my
tendency for my whole life.
My tendency is just as
events unfold in the world
is to begin forming
opinions about those events,
and then beginning to
spout those opinions off
and talk to other people
about those opinions,
before listening and before
understanding the context.
And if you say things like
white privilege is a myth.
If you say that there
is no racist oppression
in America today,
A, you're flat wrong,
and the only way to
learn that you're wrong,
is to actually learn about the history
of racism and America.
And you've gotta educate yourself,
and that doesn't mean the US history class
that you took in high school did it,
because I took that same US history class,
and they didn't talk about this stuff.
They didn't talk about
this stuff to the degree,
and with the accuracy and
the stepping out of the
traditional colonialist white perspective
in the way that Ibram is able to do,
in "Stamped From the Beginning"
and also I recommend it
for other books that are kinda
come at things from a different
angle but are all great
in the Medium article that you can...
I recommend all those and
the rest of them are shorter,
if you wanna try one of those,
I've really had to come to grips with,
the fact that being on the
sidelines of this issue
is perpetuating the problem.
There are a lot of quotes floating around
that are, say, much more
eloquently than that
but for me,
I haven't denied these problems
and I haven't sought to
actively undermine by any means.
But I feel like I've been paralyzed,
because with a combination of
just not being educated enough
and having fear about
deciding to say or do things
because we're in this environment where,
if you decide to say something,
my instinct is not to,
take as little amount
of time as possible to
understand something just
so I can then turn around
and say where I stand on it.
I'm very hesitant to take
stands on things because
I just don't have a lot of
confidence when it comes to
that type of thing.
So instead, I just get intimidated,
and just kinda move on to the next thing.
I'm troubled by it, but I'm kind of
frozen on the sidelines
and I've really come
to grips with like, I
don't wanna stay there.
It's just acknowledging the
excuses in order to work through
them to say, hey, sometimes
if you say something
and you say the wrong thing,
even if you're trying to help,
then you make people upset
that you're trying to help
or if you put anything on the internet
that shares something and that implies
that you're taking action or that
you believe other people
should also take action,
it just puts a target.
No matter what is being
said on the internet,
if you look underneath it,
most likely there someone
is very much opposed to it.
And so I wig out trying to
anticipate what that is.
It's paralyzing.
I find it really interesting
that one of the accusations,
one of the accusations
that we've received...
This year we become more vocal.
Obviously we've become more
vocal for a number of reasons.
We became more vocal once we kind of
broke the story of our
de-conversion, deconstruction
and people have perceived that we're
being more political or
talking about issues.
I think that those things just happen to
coincide in one sense, but
it also coincided with 2020,
which is a year in which
you're not getting political.
You're kind of missing the point.
You're not participating if
you're not getting political.
But I'll say that one of the
accusations that we received
sorta multiple times is
"You guys are doing this
"to please your audience."
Let me tell you everybody,
we've done nothing but lose audience.
We've done nothing but lose audience.
Every time I tweet something
that is a little bit
controversial, I lose followers.
So, we're not doing this to gain audience.
I want as many people to
stick around as possible,
but that's not why we're doing it,
but to speak to what you're talking about
with this hesitation to say something
because you feel like you're
gonna say something wrong.
First of all, you are going
to say something wrong.
When you speak into these things,
you are going to get it wrong.
And you don't mean that,
you're not singling me out.
I don't know, at this point.
Anyone who makes a decision
to try to be a part of it
is gonna get it wrong and
it's just part of the process.
But it's also the way that
we learn how to do it.
And I think you'll be surprised that
if you just take a humble posture
and you take a posture that is like,
I'm here to learn, I'm here to listen.
If I said that in the wrong way
or if I had an idea
that was actually based
in some cloak racism that I
didn't even know if I had,
point that out to me,
'cause I want to grow.
And I think another aspect of that is
the more that I listen,
the more that I learn
the better way to engage.
And this is a really recent thing for us.
I think, the way that
I have thought and felt
about these issues of
racial injustice in America
has been around for quite some time,
but the way that I'm actually
interacting and engaging
and sort of understanding
the depth of the problem,
the persistence of the problem.
That's something that's only come,
that's not gonna come by just
having a conversation with you
you know what I'm saying?
Me and you can get together
and talk and pontificate
and philosophize about everything
until the cows come home
and we're never gonna
understand the situation
that's happening in black America.
The only way you're gonna understand that,
is you have to read,
listen to black voices.
And so if you're speaking into this,
but you haven't read a book
like "Stamped From the Beginning",
you haven't listened to a talk or a video,
you're not following anybody on Twitter,
who's speaking from that perspective.
You don't have the facts.
You're coming into this with blinders on.
And it took me a long time to...
And that's not just the
case with this issue.
That's the case with every issue.
It drives me crazy.
The thing that drives me crazy is when,
if you find yourself in the wrong place,
on Twitter or scrolling
through the comments,
you get barraged,
you get pummeled by people who, there is,
I can discern no love or
empathy in their point of view.
It's one thing to disagree
or to make a counterpoint
or to come from a different place.
But that's the one thing I
do feel like I can discern,
it's kind of sniff out,
like, is there any love,
any component of love
in what you're saying?
And, that's why it's
deeply disturbing to me.
If I go to the president's
Twitter timeline,
it deeply disturbs me that I cannot dis...
I cannot pick up just a grain
of empathy in what he says.
I know we don't wanna...
It's like, well, here I am getting into...
Best, but hold on, but here's the thing.
That's not political,
that's just human intuition.
I'm being honest with you.
Like seeing the fact that our country
is going through what it's
going through right now
and we have a president who
we don't even want him to speak about it
because him speaking
about it makes it worse.
Like that's unprecedented
that we have a president
who we do not actually
want to say anything
because he will only inflame,
he will only divide.
That's not a political observation.
That's just a logical
observation about human behavior.
I don't care what side of
the spectrum you're on.
You cannot deny that fact.
He is not a leader, he is a divider.
He's making it worse.
It's the absolute last thing
that we need right now.
Hopefully it won't last much longer.
So, let's shift to a broader
topic of getting older.
But first, let's direct
you to the mythical store.
mythical.com has all types of stuff.
Don't we just sell great t-shirts?
'Cause that seems to be what
we're in the mood for today.
Well, great t-shirts in
all shapes and sizes.
You got a V neck, it's kind of a baby V.
This was your shirt.
And somehow I got it and
now it's my favorite shirt.
It got too small for me.
This is my life.
Slowly,
and I wash it too many
times, it was very clean.
The baby V I was looking in
the mirror and I was like,
Christie, do I look...
It makes my neck look so tall
and my hair is getting bigger
so now just look skinny.
I don't know, go to mythical.com
to wear stuff that makes you just right.
I saw a side-by-side or an over-under
of pre quarantine written
link on GMM in today's.
So that went up.
Yeah, I saw that
Recording this on next birthday.
And somebody was like,
"Rhett looks a little more homeless,"
or whatever the word they use was,
and Link looks smaller and skinnier.
But I looked at it and I think
it's just your hair's bigger.
And you're also kind of
like turned to the side.
I don't think you've lost that much weight
in just a couple of months, have you?
No, I lost some weight
and then I gained it back,
but I might've gained it in a
different place than my neck,
As long as you keep it
moving, keep it shifting.
mythical.com.
That was an ad.
Okay, let's get into these questions.
We'll start with Meredith Gordon,
isabeanfuzz on Twitter.
"Do you believe in the existence
of a quarter life crisis?
"I'm 37, so obviously closer
to having a midlife crisis,
"but since in quarantine,
""I've been thinking it might be possible
"to take the quarantine
quarter life crisis intensive
"and get it done before 40."
Yeah, if you're 37 and you're
having a quarter life crisis
that means that you
expect to be 148 years old
if I'm doing the math right.
But she's saying, "I'm closer
to having a midlife crisis."
I don't quarter-life crisis, I guess
would be like in your mid 20s.
But I do know,
I don't know about that.
I can relate to the fact that, like,
I mean, being in quarantine,
it's time for a lot of reflection.
And so I've definitely
found myself asking,
what is my life?
What am I doing?
I wouldn't call it a crisis.
So, de-emphasizing the word crisis,
I do think I've had like a
midlife assessment period.
There's a lot of question
marks associated with that,
but it's, turning 42 and having
time to think about it more,
I just feel like, okay,
what's the rest of my
life gonna look like?
I'm looking back at everything we've done.
And by the way, we've...
And if you listen through
a bunch of these episodes,
we've lived a bunch of life, man.
I'm super grateful.
Like, we've had great lives, multiple.
We've had multiple careers.
You've got multiple?
I feel like we've lived multiple lives.
We've had different careers.
And even in this current career,
there's been like
multiple iterations to it.
And this year, even before the pandemic,
it was kind of a transition
year for us professionally
because we had come off a touring.
We'd been ambitious
about a number of things.
And it was kind of like a regrouping phase
in order to then figure out
where we were going next
and the things we were gonna create next,
in addition to this show
and "Good Mythical Morning".
In terms of building the company,
on a lot of fronts.
I felt like I'm in this midlife mindset
even before the quarantine.
I don't know, can you relate to that?
Do you feel like you're
having a midlife crisis?
I think that the components
of a midlife crisis
and that's why you're probably feeling it
and I'm feeling it too,
you've been working towards something
and it doesn't have to
necessarily be your career
could just be like you just trying to get,
you're trying to do life.
And there's a certain part of your life
when you're really trying
hard to do life and to focus
and to move things to the next level.
And then you start crossing
over into this place
where you sorta realize that,
oh, what I was trying to accomplish
and kinda set up in my
life, it's kind of happened.
I have a house, I have a car, I have kids,
I have a relatively stable job.
And then you start
looking over the horizon
and you're like, "Oh, so it's just this.
"It's just this and it's just more of this
"and then one day I die."
And I think that, that
transitional period,
like there's a point in your life where,
when you're in college or whatever,
all you're thinking about
is what's ahead of you.
I gotta figure this out,
I gotta make the right decision
about what I'm gonna do.
And then you make...
Like for us,
we went through the different transitions
to get to the point where
we're working together
doing this stuff, and then
constantly trying to just
grind and figure it out
and build this business.
Yeah, there was so much scrambling
and yeah, for us, I'm so grateful
that we're at a place where,
we're enjoying stability,
even in the face of
what's going on economically,
relative stability for us,
not total civility, I'm
still wigging out a lot.
But the ability to have a
midlife crisis is a privilege.
It means that you've
gotten to a point where
you're actually able to stop,
step outside of your circumstances
and be like,
Is this all there is?
Is this it?
Yeah.
I talked about this book a long time ago.
You forced the recommendation out of me,
"The Second Mountain",
where it talks about,
you work really hard to
get to the first mountain.
And, you either fall
off the first mountain
or you get to the top
of it and at that point,
you realize, this can't be my mountain.
And I think that one of the
things that's coinciding
with our midlife crisis, if
that's, I will use that word.
You can use assessment,
I'll say crisis is,
I think there's no mystery
in why this is the year
that we decided to tell our
full story about the last years.
There's no mystery why I'm willing to say
the things that I say on Twitter.
And it's because I think that this life
has got to be bigger than me
just trying to be a successful person
and make it on YouTube or
whatever it is that we,
what we call what we're trying to do.
So I was like, "Oh, no,
"actually, I kinda need to think about
"the mark that I'm leaving."
Legacy.
Yeah and it's, I think that
you just naturally become...
So it's all about , everyone
is gonna have a crisis.
The question is, what
is your response to it?
Are you gonna buy a Ferrari?
Well, I'm not--
Are you just gonna become-
You know what my Ferrari is gonna be,
because I've been thinking,
I've been talking to you about this.
I've started looking at #vanlife.
I don't know what planted
this seed in my mind,
but I'm like, people are
modifying these vans,
like the sprinter vans.
And, once you click on
one of those on Instagram,
Instagram knows you wanna look
at the inside of people's vans.
So I'm like, man, these people
are like traveling around
from state to state,
sleeping and living in a van.
They're parking their van
next to a mountain lake,
opening the back doors of the van
and taking a picture
from their bed to a lake.
I saw this one clip.
I appreciate this.
Somebody had a,
they had like a GoPro
stuck to their forehead
and they got out of
their bed in their van,
they scooped up a coffee
mug, poured coffee into it,
opened the door to the van
and it was a beautiful mountain lake.
And then they walk out onto
this little stone pathway.
And then they just, with their coffee,
walk on the pathway and
just jump into the lake.
And I was like, that's gonna
be the rest of my life.
I'mma get one of these vans.
And I'm talking to you about it.
I'm talking to my kids about it.
Lando is into it, Christie's like,
"Where's the shower in this thing?"
I'm like,
"I think you have to shower
outside unless you think..."
I don't wanna be, well, first of all,
I was talking to, I told you about this.
I was talking to my friend's brother
who had a van that they were redoing
and he was creating a system
that recycled three gallons of water
so you could take a shower inside the van.
He was like trying to...
Yeah, that's right.
But he's just a dude.
And it's him and his wife.
I think you planted the
seed when you told me that.
Well, but I really, I believe in this,
but I have one hangup for me personally
and one hangup for you personally,
that I don't think no as
a showstopper necessarily.
You know me, I'm just
a big man and #vanlife
probably doesn't have a lot of
six foot, seven aficionados.
As long as your knees
bend, you'll be all right.
But the second thing
is, is that you have...
It's a family of five.
So, is this when the kids are gone?
I'm thinking about like
making a cut to the team,
to make this van life thing happen.
It's like, well, "are you in or not?
"'Cause everyone's not gonna make it."
The idea of doing van life with my family
is not something that I'm into.
I'll do a vacation with
them, I'll stay in a hotel.
I'm talking about an RV.
I'm not talking about living in a van.
I'm talking about having the ultra luxury
of just being able to get
into the van every other month
and go on like a, and it's like--
You want me to go with you?
Sometimes.
Yeah, but isn't it just one bed.
I'm not sharing a bed with you.
You are the worst person in the world
to share a bed with and I
haven't shared a bed with you.
I don't know, I'm putting
another bed on top.
You can sleep up there in a popup tent.
I need it just for the sake
of the fan fiction people,
I do need to finish that sentence though.
We used to go to conferences
when we were in college
and after college where forced
college students would
stay in one hotel room
and me and you would share like
a queen sized bed in a hotel
and you are not a good bed partner
because you move a whole lot.
I said it before, I'll say it again.
I sleep with reckless abandoned.
You wake up and your face
is right next to my face.
So I definitely do not
wanna be a part of that
if that's part of #vanlife.
You wait until you see this van.
Next question, Ruth asks,
no, that's RuthDahl 11.
"Why does time seem to move
exponentially faster each year?"
So, like when you're a kid,
everything goes so slowly.
When you're a teenager,
when you're like the more
you want time to progress,
the less it does.
And then the more you
want it to slow down,
the more it speeds up.
I guess that rings true for me.
It definitely rings true for me.
I think it rings true for a lot of people.
And so I looked up, "is there
any science behind this?"
This is what an article in
scientific American said.
"Our brain encodes new experiences,
"but not familiar ones into memory.
"And our retrospective judgment of time
"is based on how many
new memories we create
"over a certain period."
"In other words,
"the more new memories we
build on a weekend getaway,
"the longer that trip
will seem in hindsight.
"This phenomenon, which Hammond,"
Hammond is, I guess the
doctor that they're quoting.
"has dubbed "the holiday
paradox" seems to present
"one of the best clues
as to why in retrospect,
"time seems to pass more
quickly older we get."
"From childhood to early adulthood,
"we have many fresh experiences
"and learn countless new skills.
"As adults though, our
lives become more routine
"and we experience fewer
unfamiliar events."
Just like I said, is this all there is?
"As a result, our early years
"tend to be relatively overrepresented
"in our autobiographical
memory and on reflection
"seem to have lasted longer."
So it's not that in the moment...
If you sit an old person
down and a young person down
for an hour,
it's actually the probably
the younger person
who's gonna feel like that
hour is taking longer.
Oh, I'd actually, that's
consistent with it,
but it's not about that.
It's really just the
fact that you don't have
any points of reference.
You gotta have points of reference
to create memories.
New experiences.
To me, that's the thing,
and I think I'm only this van life thing
because I'm so cooped up
and I wanna go to parks now.
I wanna get out of the house again
and I want to experience adventure and
maybe it's overblown
because I'm so cooped up
and it'll dissipate over
the rest of the year
as things continue to loosen up
but fingers crossed, I don't know,
I'm not really making predictions here,
but I do like the idea of,
and we've talked about this in the past,
like creating experiences, new experiences
that enrich your life and say, you know,
I'm a creature of habit, I like to do,
I like getting things honed and perfected
and then replicated.
But it's not the,
that doesn't make for a,
for the best life necessarily.
It actually, I mean,
and according to this, the more routine,
the faster your life is gonna go.
The faster you're gonna piss it away
if you don't break out the routine.
Not even remember any of it.
Well, it's funny because
I'm not a routine guy
and I'm actually noticing
one of the things I've done consistently,
because we haven't had to
go into the office every day
and so we're not getting,
I'm getting up early,
but I'm not having to get on the road
at the same time every day.
Is that, I'm meditating
and I'm working out.
And then I'm actually
able to walk probably
with Jesse at the end of the day,
but it's getting tougher
for me because it feels
like I go and I like get up
stretch, meditate, workout.
Yeah, it's the same old thing.
Do my smoothie.
And then I'm just like, "I
gotta eat something different."
It takes me about three
weeks and I'm like,
"I've had this smoothie for three weeks."
and it's like, I start getting stir crazy.
I'm like, "I gotta have oatmeal.
"I gotta do something else to mix it up."
But the thing you're talking
about, this cooped up thing.
So I think, I don't know
if I made this a wreck.
I should've made it a wreck,
but, did I talk about
the book "Underland"?
Did I talk?
Yeah, yeah.
So when I, at the beginning of quarantine,
I was doing this exercise
where I was sort of figuring
out what my values are.
And I don't mean that in like
a family values kind of way.
I was just like,
what do I want my life to
be kinda represented by?
What I want to be present in my life.
An adventure was one of
the things that I wanted
to be present in my life.
I have a sense of adventure, you do too.
But when you get super
busy, the opportunity
or the sort of scheduling
adventures can sometimes
go by the wayside.
And what I found is that I'm just
waiting for an opportunity for a vacation.
Not anymore, but before quarantine,
it was like, "Jesse, let's
go spend a weekend in a hotel
"and what we'll do is on Saturday,
"we'll just lay by the pool."
And I kinda discovered this
like five or six years ago.
And I was like this laying next to a pool
and reading on vacation,
that's where it's at.
But I started realizing
that we were doing things
like going to Cabo for a weekend
and laying next to the pool.
And of course, it's beautiful
and I love the company
and great food, great drink, whatever.
Starts to blur together.
You're also like, "Hold on.
"But right outside the
grounds of this hotel,
"there's probably like a
cave that I could go into."
You know what I'm saying?
The thing I told Jesse, I was like,
"When we travel from now on,
"I really wanna make sure that we've got
"a balance of adventure and relaxation,"
because you don't wanna just go
and just run yourself
ragged on a vacation,
but to really think about the
opportunities for adventure
that present themselves
in any given location.
Or adventure in your own backyard.
You don't have to travel
to do it, not yet.
But I'm just saying,
that I haven't even seen
travel as primarily about adventure.
We went to France a few years
ago for that film festival
and had it...
We actually did,
what's the one thing you
remember about that trip?
What's the one thing you
tell people about this trip?
The scooter.
Almost dying on a scooter.
Yeah.
And it's like, 'cause we
made a choice for adventure.
That was the right choice, man.
That'll make your life short or long.
I didn't understand your science.
You might die, but it'll make
it make your life longer.
Grace-Anna tweeted,
"I turned 17 in just a few weeks
"and I couldn't be more
ready for my birthday
"and being one year closer to adulthood,
"but I feel like being
so eager for adulthood
"is almost wrong.
"Everyone I talk to about
this says adulthood is awful.
"How should I feel about
my impending adulthood?"
Adulthood is awful.
At 17?
Lily's 17.
It's like,
I understand you talk
about being cooped up.
There's like a certain freedom,
like wanting to get on with your own life.
As a parent, her question
makes me just think about
how I look at my family
and starting to think
as Lily's 17, Lincoln's 15, Lock is 16.
You starting to think about
them just months down the road
of like leaving the house.
They're gonna be on their own.
It's definitely another
part of aging for me.
I'm kinda co-oping her
question for me as a parent but
I start to think about things like,
when my kids get out of the house,
what are they gonna come back to?
A van, apparently.
They're gonna come back and
there's gonna be a foundation
and a van on it.
Am I building a lifestyle
for me and Christie
that is not dependent on kids
and it doesn't revolve around our kids,
but also build a future
and start to have dreams
that my kids can enter back into
but it's not all about them?
That's the next phase for us.
Lando's only 10 so.
The best way to keep
it about not about them
is as soon as they leave to go to college,
you turn their room into something else.
It doesn't even matter what it is.
It could be a gym, it could just be,
just where all the socks
that you can't match are,
you know what I'm saying?
Just take their bed,
their desk, their posters,
get rid of it all because you
want to be very clear about,
"You will not live here
after you graduate college.
"So don't get any ideas
"unless you wanna sleep on a
bunch of mismatched socks."
That's my plan.
But I started to think about like,
am I gonna live in this house?
Is this the house that
Lincoln is gonna come back to
with his...
Is this the house that they
bring their partners back to?
Their significant
others, "Hey mom and dad,
"you gotta meet Derek" I don't know.
I'm predicting there's
gonna be a Derek involved.
Jesse and I have,
we've kind of made this decision that no,
that our current house
will not be that house.
We're also like, we like change.
I'm surprised we haven't moved already,
but I think that at
this point, we're like,
we're committed to
staying in this location
until Shepherd, which is like, he's 11.
So seven more years
until he goes to college.
So maybe while they're
in college, we'd be like,
"Hey, let's try something else."
I haven't thought about
the child psychology,
because I know kids like to
come back to something familiar.
So I don't know.
I haven't thought about that aspect of it
Even seven more years in this house.
And I do start to think about that too.
It's like, I know that
there'll be a lot more
memories in this house
but there's also not,
there's not a lot of room
for someone for additional
people to come back to.
But I do start to think about that.
But to directly answer
Grace-Anna's question very quickly.
You should feel incredible about your,
it's age 17 good, listen.
The peak of your life is
right over the horizon.
Listen, you've got right now at age 17,
that there's a bunch of things
that are about to coincide.
Your level of passion for
things and your level of freedom
are about to combine in a
beautiful synergistic explosion.
And you need to realize that.
Don't wish it away.
You have this incredible
opportunity to just
not have a whole lot of responsibility.
Get a van.
Yes, get a van.
Are we talking about a gap year here?
Is that what you're talking about?
No, no.
Well, first of all, gap years
are becoming very common
because of quarantine,
because of the coronavirus.
The whole world is in a gap year.
Right but no, gap year, yes.
But I'm just talking about the fact that,
you're gonna feel like college is a lot,
but just let me tell you, it's not.
It's like don't,
I'm not saying don't study.
I'm just saying that
don't fall for the lie
that it's a lot.
It's freedom, it's free.
And not everybody goes to college.
But what I'm saying is, before that
you got this gap between
being under your parents' roof
and then having a roof
with other people under it.
There's this window.
That's the window of opportunity.
You know what I'm saying?
Just see it for what it is.
Enjoy it.
Nouisxsweet.
There's no name associated with
this, but that's the handle.
It looks like Louis but with an N.
"What do you think is a turning
point for becoming an adult?
"I'm currently 18 and my
life hasn't changed that much
"these past years and I
can't see myself as an adult.
"Is it getting a job.
"a degree or is it just a matter of age?"
Kennedy, @kennedygerow, kind
of adds to this question.
"At what point in your life did you feel
"like you actually had
a good handle on things?
"I just graduated college
and I will start my first,
"big girl job soon and
I'm very overwhelmed."
It's like trying to figure out
when are you an adult
and when do you feel like
you have a handle on things?
I've said before that...
Yeah, Christie's back there.
She's mouthing "never".
Yeah, that's exactly right.
I mean, I think I've thought before.
I felt like I've said before that,
I feel like I'm an adult
when I had responsibility,
definitely having kids made me feel like,
oh, well I'm not the kid
because now I have one.
That must make me the adult.
But it was something that I
kinda had to stop and derive.
Well, yes.
To me, I think the moment
that you become an adult
is when you have the realization
that no one has a handle on things.
Like it's the moment in which you are,
which is like all of a
sudden, you look around
and you're like, "Oh,
"They also don't know what
the hell they're doing.
"This is great.
"They're all faking it.
"They're all faking that
they've got it figured out."
That's the moment you become an adult
because when you're a child,
you look up usually because you're short
and you see these adults and
they just, they seem like,
I mean, they're moving and then...
Their shirts are total direction britches.
And they're like cranking up cars
and like jogging and bringing in food.
They're doing lots of
things that seem purposeful,
that make you feel stable.
But then when you become
that person and you're like,
I'm kinda just doing what
they did, but hold on.
I don't really know what I'm doing.
I feel overwhelmed.
I don't have a handle on things.
That's the realization, that's
when you become an adult.
Well, Lisa @BleedBlueBurgun
tweeted, one of these
usernames are crazy.
Lisa said, "I think this quote
"would be a cool topic
point on getting older.
"This is from Alden Nowlan."
Nowlan never heard of this guy, have you?
"The day the child realizes
that all adults are imperfect,
"he becomes an adolescent.
"The day he forgives them,
he becomes an adult."
That's an eloquent way of saying
what we're talking about.
Same thing we were saying,
that there's a level of maturity
associated with realizing that no one is,
everyone's imperfect.
Nobody's got everything figured out.
No one makes the right decision.
Everybody's in need of forgiveness.
And if you can give that,
I think that's a,
I think that's a good measuring stick
for adulthood, for maturity.
If you can forgive people and
probably forgive yourself too
and give yourself an end to say,
"Hey, we're all just, we're all just,
"we're all stumbling forward
in time towards our own demise
"but we might as well live
it up in the meantime."
'Cause another aspect of it,
I don't remember exactly
the moment that this hit me,
but there was a moment
in which I found myself
living through a personal
moment in my life
that coincided with the
first memory of my parents.
Does that make sense?
So, when I started realizing, like,
I remember like seeing
my parents be parents,
there was a moment that I can remember
my parents doing parental things.
And then there's a moment in which
you see yourself doing the same thing
and that's when you can begin to get
to that point of forgiveness.
You're like, "Damn, it's
hard to be a parent."
You had sympathy for your own parents
and even though it doesn't help,
I tell my 16 year old this all the time.
It's like, "I can't wait
till you have your own kids."
I mean, that's
a pointless thing to say.
Cliche.
And I shouldn't say it,
I say it in frustration,
but it's also true because
there will come a time
I'm hoping that there will
be a phone call or an email,
or at least a text that is just like,
"Okay, dad, I get it."
You know what I'm saying?
And I think that's the moment.
That's another way to
kind of gauge adulthood.
You don't have to be a parent.
It could be a stage of life
where you can relate
to another generation.
Did you ever have that
moment with your parents
where you were like, "You
know what, I get it."
It's funny today,
I talked to my mom, she
wished me happy birthday
and she was like,
"Well, I wanna know, do
you feel old as dirt?"
And I was like, I laughed.
And she was like, "When I turned 42,
"I remembered that you told me,"
"Man, mom, you're old as dirt."
She held on to that.
"So now that you're 42,
do you feel old as dirt?"
And she said she remembered it.
She's been waiting all these years.
I don't remember saying that to her.
I'm sure it was a joke.
She basically said it was a joke.
But, do you...
There is an aspect of aging that is,
you talk to your parents differently.
Was there a point where
you, just the way that
you're waiting for Lock
to text you and say,
"You know what, I get it."
Do you recall giving that to your parents?
The way that that comes up for me is,
I don't do this all the time,
but I'm not necessarily
great at saying it.
I'm pretty good at writing it.
And so, in a number of
cards over the years,
whether it's Father's Day, Mother's Day,
birthday or whatever,
and again, I'm not super
consistent in this,
but I've definitely have specific memories
of sitting down and being,
I'm going to write how
much I appreciate that,
how my mom mothered me,
how my father fathered
me because I get it.
Understanding how meaningful it was
to have my dad present
for all my sporting events
and stuff like that and
growing up and realizing,
"Damn, that's really hard to do."
That took intention and sacrifice.
So acknowledging that in
cards is what you've done?
Yeah, I'm not saying we
haven't talked about it,
but I'm saying that I, in some fashion,
even though I'm not the best communicator,
I have communicated that to
them as I've grown older.
I remember one time when I was in college,
my dad had a camper and
he took it to Jordan Lake
and me and my dad,
this was like the first
time ever that me and my dad
like did a camping trip,
like sleepover thing
where it was just the two of us.
And I remember we were sitting
out there at Jordan Lake
and we cracked open a beer,
we like shared a beer.
Well, we each had our own beer.
And I just remember that
being a milestone moment.
I remember being nervous going.
I was like, "I'm driving out
here and meeting my dad."
I never lived with my dad
except in like visitation situations.
But it was really cool
because like all of a sudden
we were two guys doing things that
we would both do with our friends,
but we were doing it with each other
and we were having a conversation
that we would each have with a friend.
And I mean, that was a long
time coming from me and my dad,
because we never lived together.
There are elements of
that with all of my kids,
like I try to speak to them.
I talk to them about
things and I talk to them
in ways that I would talk to you sometimes
depending on the subject matter.
There are these parents who,
they never stop baby talking their kids,
even when they're adults.
I know of people, I'm not close to people,
but I've observed people
who would still talk
kind of like baby talk to their,
their daughter or son that's in their 20s.
What?
Yeah.
I'm thinking of one person in particular
that you, but you don't know them.
We need to talk about this after,
because I don't know
There's parents who never change
how they talk to their children
and that's just not good.
I never baby talked either of my kids.
I just baby talk the dog.
I figured that she can take
it for her entire life.
But I look forward to having
an adult to adult
relationship with my kids.
That's why I like to
picture them once they leave
coming back and whether
it's here or somewhere else,
like I wanna create an environment where
they wanna be a part of
me and Christie's lives.
Well, you know, the way to do that.
The way to do that is...
Probably a beach house.
Yes, you get, either get a beach house.
If we're so blessed to
be able to afford one,
or you rent a beach house
and taking your adult
children on vacation,
that's how you keep them.
That's how you keep 'em around
because they are not
gonna be able to afford
their own vacation.
They're all going into this world
that's gonna be all the robots
are gonna have the jobs.
They're gonna wanna go on
vacation with you forever.
They're gonna want it.
They're going to wanna like
take the hibernation pill
and then only wake up for hibernation
to go--
For a vacation.
With me and then just hibernate again.
And I think that what we're gonna do,
and we'll still be making
content on some level.
Maybe we'll still be making this podcast.
I think that we need to commit right now
that we're going to be the parents
that they want to go on vacation with.
You know what I'm saying?
You gotta think about it.
There needs to be a survey or something.
We gotta do like a kid's
focus group to be like,
what makes going on vacation
with people miserable
and make sure that we're not
the ones contributing to that.
Whatever that is, let's commit to that.
Because somebody has got the ability
to pay for your vacation,
doesn't make the vacation fun.
No.
Those are two completely different things.
All right, Erika with a K,
very active mythical beast.
She's got a...
Her question was so intense and so long
that it took two tweets.
"Looking back at myself in my twenties
"and even early thirties
and realizing that
"many of my opinions and
viewpoints were still being formed
"by my parent.
"I feel like I didn't start
forming independent thoughts
"until later in life.
"When do you think you start
truly having opinions and views
"that wouldn't necessarily
be approved by your parents?
"Do you think the need for approval
"from such major influences, parents
"slows down progressive
changes in societal issues?"
Whoa, this is a big one to get
into right here at the end.
Let's just say, yes.
She asked me, that's my answer, yes.
#EarBiscuits, let's know what you think.
No, we're gonna answer it.
So, you know, when we
talked about the last years,
we kinda told our life story
and that we were raised
in a very particular
sort of way of thinking
and we don't think that
way exactly anymore.
And first of all, that's
a super common thing
not just today with us, been a
super common thing throughout
the history of the world,
especially post-industrial revolution,
there's lots of societal
generational changes
that take place pretty quickly.
And the older generations
is like "Back in my day,
"we didn't think like this."
But so anyway, and also
most child psychologists
suggest that a child sees a structure,
and most kids need to sort of
rebel through that structure,
even if they kinda come back to it.
And Jesse and I were talking
about our personalities
and we are both rule followers.
I'm a three on the
Enneagram, I'm a performer,
but one of the great ways to
kinda exercise your threeness
is to recognize
how to succeed within a
framework and then be like,
"Oh, I can do that, that's what I did."
"I did well in school,
"I did well in sports and I was a good kid
"that made my parents proud."
It was really good at that.
Jesse's a two on the Enneagram,
which is not about achieving,
but it's more about
helping people do things
and basically being there for people,
but in the same way that
she's a rule follower.
So we got well into
adulthood, into our 30s,
still holding very tightly
to basically the things
that we have been taught in
our parents that taught us.
But we were also then talking about
a guy that we went to high school with,
I'm not gonna name his name,
that was a friend of ours
who also went to church with us.
But then all of a
sudden, you remember this
prom one year, junior year or senior year,
he showed up dressed,
In a dress.
But not just dressed as a woman,
like he had on makeup
and he had done his hair
and it almost was like so well done
that the first thing I thought
was, who's the new girl?
I remember thinking that.
And then the second thing I thought was
that's so-and-so so-and-so
and with the time I was like,
Oh, that's a funny joke.
Like, I wasn't like, I
can't believe he did that.
I remember just thinking that, like,
that was really bold and very funny.
He really pulled that off,
but I didn't stop and
think, why did he do that?
As we grew up a little
bit, I realized that, oh...
He was making a statement.
He checked out.
He rebelled against the system
that he saw in place at the time.
He just did it in high school
and then he went out to college,
and became an adult who was somebody
that didn't hold to the same
worldview as his parents.
But it took me to get to in my 30s,
before I began to
investigate the worldview.
And I'm not saying that
this isn't really a truth,
non true, whether it's true or not,
that's not what I'm...
We talked about that a
lot in the last years.
This is more about like
the way that you think
and the way that you see the world,
have you ever made it personal?
You may just you may transfer
the same exact worldview
that was handed to you by your
parents and make it personal
and actually passionately
interact with it.
But usually the process of actually
wanting to kinda take
control and make it your own,
one of two things happen,
you grab hold of it and
it slips out of your hand.
You realize that's not for
me or you grab hold of it
and you realize that it
fits your hands perfectly
and you adopt it.
But different personalities
make that decision
at different times.
I kinda got all the way through my 20s,
still in a very performance
oriented mindset
where it was about
making my parents proud.
And that's not every,
I think Erika is saying that
she's the same kind of person.
My wife's the same kind of person,
but a lot of people, including the guy
we're talking about who we
went to high school with,
it happened earlier for him.
Yeah, I think for me too it was.
If you tell me the right way to do it
and enough people agree, then it's just,
this is the safe, secure
path and I'm gonna,
I can feel okay.
I can feel confident and it's,
I didn't have this sense of
needing to discover myself
or express myself in a way
that was counter to anything
that I was, the plans that I was adopting.
I just wanna feel okay.
I just wanna feel safe.
I don't wanna feel like
I'm out here on a limb
trying to figure this out.
I just didn't have, I
didn't have that drive.
I had another drive, I
had to drive for security.
And so yeah, it was,
I think it did take a long time for me
to start to figure out who I was for me
and not for anybody else.
And then, we got married so young
that you transfer from,
okay, this is the family
that I grew up in.
This is a system that works there to...
Now this is the family that I've formed.
And I gotta meet Christie's expectations.
She's gotta meet my expectations.
It's like, you go from one
to another, at least we did.
Yeah, well into the second
part of the question about,
"Do you think this slows down
"progressive changes in societal issues?"
Definitely it does, but, and I'm not
listen, I didn't study this.
This is total Rhett
pulling it out of his ass,
which is a good bit of what I say,
but my theory on this,
the way that I think about
like societal progression,
I think one of the big changes
in worldview that happened,
like when I was a evangelical Christian,
I saw the world as getting
progressively worse
'cause that's consistent with eschatology.
The idea that things are gonna slowly get
progressively worse and then
Jesus is gonna come back.
Now that I don't believe that anymore
and I'm more progressive in my mindset.
I actually think that the
world is getting better.
And I actually think if
you read Steven Pinker's
latest book, I think the
facts are on the side of it.
Actually, even though
it seems more chaotic
and you're getting a lot more
information that makes it
seem even right now with riots
happening throughout the,
throughout the nation, you may be,
"Oh everything's going crazy."
Well, in reality, basically every marker
that you can measure, society
is getting better over time.
So I think the facts are on the side of
things are progressing.
But what I've always said is that
stretching progression like you know,
social progressive stuff is like
stretching the fabric of society.
And it eventually fills
in and you stretch it.
And I think that people only have
so much capacity for change.
It's like you pull it,
you pull it too hard
and sometimes it rips and
then you've gotta stitch it
and you gotta keep pulling.
I believe that you keep pushing things
in the right direction.
And to me, it's just a good
segue to zoom out and say,
I feel like what's going on right now.
We're at such a pivotal
moment in history and
it's such an important moment in time that
we can choose to be on the sidelines
be part of the problem,
be a part of the solutions
be a part of the evolution,
the positive evolution of society
and I do have hope, to
bring the full circle
as we listen, and as we have
open minds and open hearts,
that it's a privilege
to have the opportunity
to be a part of what's happening now.
And it's scary
and there's no clear path
forward on a number of fronts.
What you think about racial injustice,
what you think about the environment,
what you think about this pandemic,
you can add things to the list.
But we're a part of it
and we can impact it
and we can do that stretching.
I'm choosing to find hope in that
and to find a way to be a part of it
and to move forward and not
just try to escape or ignore,
or just get old.
Yeah, well, and I think
that you were talking about
earlier the aspect of
feeling like you're standing
on the sidelines sometimes.
And I think everybody
probably has a tendency
to feel that way.
The way that I've kind
of seen my role in this
stretching of societal fabric
over the course of my life
is that first of all,
my personality is one who is naturally
gonna grab onto the blanket.
I'm going to grab onto the fabric.
That's just the kinda way I live my life.
And I spent a good portion of my life
pulling on one side of that fabric,
trying to keep it in place.
And I feel like one of
the things that I'm doing
in the second half of my life is saying,
"I actually feel like I was wrong
"and I'm moving to the
other side of the blanket
"and I'm pulling on it."
And that's kinda the way that I see
the two halves of my life
and the way I've kinda
contributed to what Erika
is kind of talking about,
these bigger societal issues.
And so in some ways I kind of feel like
I'm making up for things and that's just,
I don't know if that's right or wrong,
but that's how I interact with it.
And I don't think, and I do think that
there was sort of this middle period where
it was kinda like, all right,
I'm gonna let go of the blanket.
I'm letting go of the fabric
everybody's pulling on.
I'm gonna just watch for a little bit.
And then once I was like, "Okay,
"I think I know what
direction I wanna pull."
I've just been pulling it harder.
In the context of aging,
we've talked about being engaged.
You can let life pass you by, as they say,
you can let life happen to you
or you can happen to life.
I think that's the thing that I want to,
I want to be engaged.
I want to be happening to life
and not life just happening to me.
Life throws a lot at
us and there's things,
but when you respond,
we do have the ability to engage.
And I think that that's
again, that's exciting
and that's a place where
there's hope in that.
Yeah, well, and the last thing I'll say is
I think that the biggest difference
with the way that I
engage about these things,
and specifically like the
issue of racial injustice,
I think that I spent a
good portion of my life
thinking about what I had
to protect personally.
Like what were my rights and my interests
and how do I hold tightly to those
and how do I protect those?
And I think one of the biggest
changes that has taken place
over the past decade is trying
to think a little bit less
about what I have and what my rights are
and think about people who
have been marginalized,
people who have been denied rights,
people who have been denied opportunity,
people who don't have the
same opportunity that I have
and think, "Oh, okay,
"I kinda wanna realign my
actions, the way I give
"the way I spend my time
and the things I say
"and who I vote for,"
to take those people into account
rather than just think about
what I have and what's mine
and what I can protect.
And that may be an oversimplification,
but it's been helpful for
me to see it that way.
And I think it's a good
sort of North star as like,
are you thinking about yourself
or are you thinking about others?
'Cause you only got one life to live
unless we have more
that I don't know about.
You won't know and if you do,
you probably won't remember it
unless you adhere to a
particular faith system
that recognizes that and
then you do some sort of
exploration of your past lives.
But who's to say that
you'll be able to do that.
You might find your self in
a worldview that denies that,
and you'll miss out all the opportunities
of living your subsequent lives.
#EarBiscuits.
If anything we've said,
except for the very last part,
even that I don't care,
Even that man.
Has given you something
that you wanna weigh in on,
please do that.
Let's keep the conversation going.
And I look forward to maybe not,
not being in separate places for the next
"EarBiscuits" next week,
but we will speak at you
Fingers crossed.
And thanks for your questions as always,
you're contributing to the conversation,
let's carry the conversation
on, on the internet
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right,
to watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.